(slurred)
Yeah, this is pretty bad.
But honestly,
I know my limit.
I'm just pacing myself
for that lava cake.
Okay, you've absolutely
reached the limit.
Your face looks like
the underbelly of a tugboat.
Listen, we are here
celebrating
your birthday, okay?
Yeah, and for my
birthday
I would love
for you to stay alive.
Abbi, I am a veteran
of this game.
I got three to
three and a half servings
of shellfish left in me.
I feel it.
And then my throat's
gonna start to close up
and you'll just stab me
with an epi pen.
It's not a big deal.
Where am I getting
an epi pen?
From my clutch.
Durr!
So you planned on having me
stab you with an epi pen?
(more slurred)
You know, stop trying
to change the subject.
What did Doug say to you
on the phone?
Okay, so,
it turns out that, um,
he wasn't wearing
a condom last night.
What?!
It had to have been
the condom
from the other night
with boring Ben,
which means that...
there was a condom
in my person for four days.
Normally,
I would be overjoyed
that you had sex
twice in one week.
Okay, I could have sworn
that he was--
You could have
sworn what?
Not only are we
talking STDs here,
I can't even imagine
how many dudes
would love to lock you down
with an unexpected pregnancy.
I mean,
what do you think--
All right,
the Alaskan king crab stew.
And I do hope
you ladies enjoy it.
Thank you
so much, John.
Eww.
I mean, your body
is a temple.
(slurping)
You've got to respect it.
Ilana, stop,
that's enough.
No, enough.
Hey, two more bites.
It is so expensive.
Ilana, stop eating--
okay.
We're not doing this
anymore.
No, one more,
one more.
Come on,
take this pen.
Hey!
No, no!
Ilana, take the pen.
Aah! God!
(diners groan)
I stabbed myself.
(gasps)
I just
stabbed myself!
Whoo!
Adrenaline!
I... could actually
take that pen.
(wheeze)
I feel so alive
right now!
What's going on?
Ilana,
I got you, girl.
It's my birthday,
I'm the king of the world!
Wait, wait.
We'll take those two
molten lava cakes to go.
(shudders)
26, 26!